no ha habido hoy en Rusia grandes
eventos públicos para recordar el inicio
de lo que el gobierno ruso sigue
llamando operación militar especial ayer
sí que vimos fuegos artificiales porque
era el día del defensor de la patria una
fiesta que se ha querido ligar esta vez
al esfuerzo bélico no del pasado como
pasaba antes cuando se hablaba de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial sino el que
actualmente se está llevando a cabo en
Ucrania por su parte el gobierno ruso
trata de imprimir una moral de Victoria
Aunque para muchos rusos como mucho hay
moral a secas los precios de los
productos básicos han subido y sobre
todo no sé vislumbra una salida al
conflicto a corto plazo lo más
preocupante para la población empezó en
los meses de septiembre octubre cuando
se desató el reclutamiento masivo de
ciudadanos todavía hay miedo a que eso
vuelva a ocurrir y por eso Muchos rusos
han decidido no volver todavía a Rusia
hasta que no se aclare lo que está
pasando en el